The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Okay.
Today we are going to continue
where we left off with kinetics.
And so the topics we are going
to cover today,
we are going to talk about
radioactive decay,
which is an example of a first
order process.
Then we are going to talk about
second order integrated rate
laws.
Then we are going to something
that I love, which is to go back
and connect the first topic that
I taught in the second half of
the semester,
chemical equilibrium,
with kinetics.
So we are integrating all the
material from this half of the
course.
And then we are going to start
talking about reaction
mechanisms.
And, on Wednesday,
we will talk more about
reaction mechanisms.
And so this will move you
closer to being able to do more
of the problems on Problem Set
10.
Again, we are going to be in
kinetics for the rest of the
semester.
Other topics we will cover
after mechanism,
we will talk about temperature,
and we will talk about
catalysts as well.
Most of kinetics is in Chapter
13, but the little bit we are
going to do on radioactive decay
is in Chapter 17.
Just to review where we were on
Friday, we were talking about
half-life for a first-order
process.
First-order half-life.
Half-life is just the time it
takes for half of the original
material to go away,
and its symbol is t one half.
Last time we took the first
order integrated rate law,
and we were able to solve for
an expression for half-life.
And all we had to do is say all
right, by definition,
when half of the original
material has gone away,
then your t is equal to t a
half.
It is the half-life.
And then the expression for the
original material,
so that is the concentration of
A to the O, the original
material drops out.
And we find that for a
half-life expression,
it is independent of a
concentration that you started
with, so it depends,
then, on the rate constant k.
An example of a first order
process is radioactive decay.
Radioactive decay,
the rate at which it happens is
independent of the number of
nuclei that surround the
material.
That is another way of saying,
it is independent of the
concentration.
This is a first-order process.
And so we can use the same
things we learned on Friday,
when we were talking about
concentrations of material and
apply them to radioactive decay.
So, because this is first-order
here, it is independent of the
surrounding nuclei,
we can apply these first-order
integrated rate laws that we
derived on Friday.
Here were the ones we derived
on Friday.
We found that the concentration
of a material A,
at some given time,
is equal to its original
concentration times e to the
minus kt, where k is the rate
constant and t is the time.
And we just looked at this
again, that the half-life for a
first order process is equal to
0.6931 over that rate constant.
Now we can take these equations
and just rewrite them in terms
of nuclei, because we are
talking about radioactive decay.
Instead of concentration,
then, we are going to use this
term N, which is the number of
nuclei.
We can put that in,
instead.
Now, we have a new expression,
where N, the number of nuclei
at some given time,
is equal to N nought here,
the number of original nuclei
in the sample,
e to the kt.
And k is
a rate constant,
but now it is called the decay
constant because we are talking
about radioactive decay.
But it is the same principle.
It is just a slightly different
word for it.
And you have time.
So it is the same expression.
Instead of concentration,
we have number of nuclei.
Chemical kinetics is talking
about monitoring changes of
concentration over time,
whereas nuclear kinetics is
talking about measuring decay
events.
And so here,
we would be measuring with a
Geiger counter,
detecting radiation.
Over here you are measuring
changes of concentration of
material.
I just brought a Geiger counter
with me.
If we turn this on,
we can see if we have any
radioactivity in the room.
The radiation will cause an
ionization and cause a current
flow, and the current flow
causes clicking.
We will see how clean the
classroom is over here.
Can you hear it?
It seems pretty good.
I will check over there later
just to be sure that we are
free.
My lab uses X-rays to determine
structures of enzymes.
We need this to check to make
sure we have no leaks in our
X-ray generator,
that we are not exposing
anybody who comes by the
laboratory.
That is how you could measure
whether there was any
radioactivity,
and how it would change.
And, if there is a lot of
radioactivity,
then you start hearing the
clicks much faster.
We can also talk about activity
of a sample.
And activity is abbreviated A
here.
And so the activity or the
decay rate is just the change in
the number of nuclei,
remember N is the number of
nuclei, over time.
And so activity would then be
equal to the decay constant
times the number of nuclei that
you have.
And because the activity would
be proportional to the number of
nuclei, you can also take the
expressions that we just looked
at.
We just looked at this
expression, that the number of
nuclei that you have at some
given time is equal to the
number that you had originally
times e to the minus kt,
the decay constant times time.
You can also express that in
terms of activity.
Here we have the activity of
the sample at some given time is
equal to the original activity
that the sample had,
e to the kt,
the decay constant times time.
You could use either one of
these, depending on what you are
given in a particular problem.
In terms of units,
then, the SI unit for activity
is Bq, becquerel.
And this is equal to one
radioactive disintegration per
second.
And the older unit,
which you probably have heard
of, is called the curie.
And one curie is equal to
3.7x10^10 disintegrations per
second.
Does anybody know which curie
this is named after?
I heard some here and some
here.
There are only two really
guesses here.
It is actually Pierre Curie.
I always assumed,
until I looked this up
recently, that it would have
been Marie Curie.
After all, she was the first
woman to receive a Nobel Prize,
so I figured she could have a
unit named after here.
But, in fact,
it was her husband that the
unit was named after.
And she was involved in naming
the unit after her husband.
And it was named after him
because of his untimely death in
1906, I think it was.
He was killed in some kind of
road accident.
And some people speculate that
the effects of radiation were
already upon him.
And he wasn't paying so much
attention.
Maybe it was the absent-minded
professor thing.
I don't know.
Anyway, he ended up having an
unfortunate accident and having
the unit named after him.
He did share with his wife the
Nobel Prize before he died,
but his wife went on to win a
second Nobel Prize after his
death.
She got two Nobel Prizes,
and he got one and a unit named
after him.
Although, the unit is no longer
used.
She probably got the better
deal in long-term history.
One thing I will mention is
that at the time,
the reason why it was changed
is this is a pretty inconvenient
unit.
This is a really big number
right here.
And, at the time,
they were deciding what this
unit should be,
it was pointed out that this
was kind of an inconvenient
number.
This is way more radiation than
a normal sort of worker with
radiation would be handling.
But Marie Curie put her foot
down, apparently,
and said that she didn't want
her husband's name associated
with a unit that represented an
infinitesimally small quantity
of material.
As a consequence,
this is a large number that was
impractical and later
substituted.
The person that Marie and
Pierre Curie shared the Nobel
Prize with was Henry Becquerel.
Apparently, his wife had no
objections.
And so now a much smaller unit
is named after him.
Whenever I talk about this,
I always ask,
it makes me curious whether
there is a unit that is named
after a woman.
As you go through MIT,
you might want to check with
your professors where these
units came from.
And if you find one that is
named after a woman,
please let me know,
because I am not aware of any
and it is sort of a curiosity of
mine if such a thing exists.
The current unit up here,
and this is the older unit.
Okay.
We are not going to do much in
Chapter 17, but a little bit on
some of the types.
This is just a table in your
book.
I didn't put it in your
handout, because I don't expect
you to really know any of this.
It will be presented in the
problem if you need to know it.
But just to mention types of
radiation, alpha decays and beta
decays.
Alpha decay,
the particle that you are
talking about,
is equivalent to a helium four
nucleus.
Beta decay equivalent to an
electron.
Sometimes you get a change in
mass.
Sometimes you get a change only
in atomic number.
And the half-lives are very
different.
Again, you don't need to know
this, but you will need to look
this up for some of the problems
that you do, what the half-life
is.
And this is right out of your
book.
I think a few problems require
you to go back to this table and
look up the half-life for a
particular material in question.
I am going to do an example of
radioactive decay.
And, to do this,
I am going to turn to poetry
for this particular example.
One of our chemistry grad
students, Mala Radhakrishnan,
is also a poet.
And so this is one of her
poems, Days of our Half-Lives.
And this is published in a
collection of poetry all about
chemistry.
She is now working on a
biochemistry book,
if anybody is interested.
This is Chemistry for the Coach
Potato.
Here poem has to do with
uranium-238.
And this is in your handout,
this particular chart.
Here, alpha decays are
indicated by this yellow line,
and the beta decay is in the
blue line here.
And so here is uranium-238 at
the very top,
and this is all the various
things that can happen to
uranium-238 as it goes through a
series of alpha and beta decays.
This is Days of Our Half-Lives.
My dearest love,
I am writing you,
to tell you all that I have
been through.
I have changed my whole
identity, but loved I can't
pretend to be.
When I was uranium-238,
you were on my case to start
losing weight.
For five-billion years I'd hope
and I'd pray,
and, finally,
I had an alpha decay.
Two protons,
two neutrons went right out the
door, and now I was thorium-234.
But my nucleus was still unfit
for your eyes,
not positive enough for its
large size.
But this time,
my half-life was not very long,
because my will to change was
really quite strong.
It took just a month,
not even a millennium,
to beta decay into
protactinium.
But you still rejected me,
right off the bat.
"Protactinium?
Who's heard of that?" So a beta
decay I did once more,
to become uranium-234.
Myself again,
but a new isotope.
You still weren't satisfied,
but I still had hope.
Three alpha decays,
it was hard,
but I stayed on,
through thorium again,
then radium,
then radon.
I thought that I would finally
please you.
My mass was a healthy 222.
But you said,
"Although I like your mass,
I don't want to be with a noble
gas!" You had a point,
I was not reactive.
So in order to please you,
I stayed proactive.
A few days later I found you
and said, "Two more alpha decays
and now I am lead!"
You shook your head.
You weren't too keen of my mass
number of 214.
I had a bad experience with
that mass before,
an unstable acetone walked
right out the door.
So in order to change,
I went away,
but all I could do was just
beta decay.
My hopes and my dreams started
to go under, because beta decays
do not change a mass number.
To bismuth, then polonium,
I hoped and I beckoned,
my half-life was 164
microseconds.
And then I alpha decayed,
and then I was lead,
with a prize-worthy mass of
210.
You've got to admit I was
getting quite tired,
and my patience with you had
nearly expired.
You were more demanding than
any I had dated,
and much of my energy had
already been liberated.
You still weren't happy,
but I had a fix.
I really liked the number 206.
So I waited for years until the
day which began with another
beta decay.
And then one more.
And finally in the end I
alpha-ed to lead 206,
my friend.
To change any further,
I wouldn't be able,
no longer active,
but happily stable.
It took me billions of years to
do, but look how I have changed.
And all just for you.
And what did you say?
I had gotten so old that you'd
rather be with a young lass of
gold.
Well, I give up.
We are through,
my pumpkin.
Shouldn't all my efforts be
countin' for something?
Well, you won't be able to rule
me anymore, because I am leaving
you, not for one atom but for
four.
That is right.
While you were away diffusing,
I met some chlorines that I
found quite amusing.
And we are going to form lead
Cl four and you won't
be hearing from me anymore.
So over the years I have grown
quite wise.
I have learned that love is
about compromise.
You still have half of your
half-lives to give.
So now you go out there,
it is your turn to give.
Okay, so there is an example of
radioactive decay that brought
us all the way up here to all
the way down here.
All right.
Now let's actually look at an
example of how we might work a
problem.
And if anyone else has any
poetry suggestions for other
topics in freshman chemistry,
feel free to submit those as
well.
Okay.
Now let's just work an example.
We want to find the original
activity and the activity after
17 years, which is equivalent to
5.4x10^8 seconds of 0.5 grams of
plutonium-239.
And this is the half-life in
years and also in seconds.
We can use this equation.
We want to find activity,
and original activity.
And we need to know original
number of nuclei and the decay
constant.
But, before we can use that,
we have to find the decay
constant and the number of
nuclei to be able to find the
original activity.
First, we can look at the
number of original nuclei.
And so we were given that there
were 0.5 grams.
We can convert that with the
atomic weight.
And here, you want to use the
atomic weight that is given in
the form of that isotope.
You don't need to look this up
in the Periodic Table.
You just take that number,
which is given to you,
and plug it in down here.
Then we need to convert with
this number, which is what?
Avogadro's number.
Convert the number of nuclei
that are in one mole.
And so then we can get the
number of nuclei originally in
this sample, in 0.5 grams of
this sample.
That is 1.3x10^21 nuclei.
Then we can find k.
How can we find k with what is
given here?
What do we know that is useful?
We know the half-life,
right.
We can easily find k from
half-life by the equation for a
first-order half-life process.
That is just 0.6931 over the
half-life.
And the only thing tricky here
is you want to make sure that
you are going to have all your
units come out okay,
so either all in years or all
in seconds.
If we plug in the second value
here, we can get our decay
constant k in seconds,
9.1x10^-13 seconds to the minus
one.
Now we have a number of nuclei
originally present and the decay
constant, so we can calculate
the original activity.
And so we can just plug that
in.
And so we get,
for our units,
we have nuclei per second.
And one disintegration per
second is a becquerel.
Nuclei per second is just a
becquerel.
That is in Bq.
See, that is a more convenient
unit than the curie.
That is our original value.
Now, if we want to know,
after 17 years,
how much activity is left,
we can use this equation down
here.
That the activity at some given
time is equal to the activity
originally times e to the minus
kt, where that is the decay
constant and time.
We can plug in our original
activity that we just
calculated, put in our decay
constant which we calculated up
here, and here we just have to
make sure we have the same
units.
Seventeen years was converted
to number of seconds,
and we can put that in,
and we can solve,
and we get the same answer.
To the significant figures,
it is the same.
So no significant difference.
And this is one of the problems
with materials that are
radioactive, is that they are
around for a very long time.
And so one problem with
radioactive material is how are
you going to store it?
A lot of times the materials we
have to store things do not last
as long as the material we are
trying to store.
This is a problem that every
once in a while gets talked
about in the general media and
in political discussions.
But here is an example that
these things are around for
quite a long time.
All right.
I will just mention a use of
radioactive decay.
A lot of people think of
radioactive materials and get
sort of frightened by them,
but they actually can be very
useful and they can save lives
and make money.
Here is an example from MIT.
This is a picture of Alan
Davison, who has just retired
last year from the Chemistry
Department.
And he paid attention to some
freshman chemistry stuff and
figured out a good way of making
a material that could be used
for imaging.
And so what he did,
he has this technetium.
And he figured out how to put
it in a coordination complex
that had just kind of the right
sort of properties that you want
for imaging.
It wouldn't be in the system
very long, it wouldn't be too
harmful, but yet it would give
you some good scans.
And so he paid attention to
metals in this d-block area that
we have been talking about.
And he said,
how can I put this together in
a coordination complex that
would have just the right
properties?
He took one of these guys,
in gray, are some of the ones
that have been used in medicine
that are not naturally occurring
in the body, and made a
coordination complex.
And the ligands he chose were
cyanide ligands to get the
desired properties.
And this patent for Cardiolite
has made a lot of money,
which is really putting it very
mildly.
The patents,
there is money to MIT,
to Alan Davison himself,
other people involved.
And the Chemistry Department
has gotten money for this,
too.
And over the last ten years,
a lot of sort of discretionary
funds and scholarships and other
things we have been able to do
has all been a result of this.
Now the patent just expired on
this.
We are looking for other people
who pay attention in freshman
chemistry to come up with some
basic principles,
put it together,
and have a new patent that
would allow us to kind of carry
on.
We liked having all of this
extra money around.
So you can be thinking about
that.
Just sort of basic principles
here.
And it has also saved a lot of
lives.
They have moved on and tried to
use it now for imaging different
kinds of cancers and things like
that.
It is really a pretty wonderful
material.
All right.
Radioactivity can be difficult
to store, but it also can be
very useful.
That is first-order processes.
Radioactive decay is one of the
best examples of a first-order
process.
Now let's talk about
second-order.
And so what we are going to do
now is we are going to derive,
as we did for the first-order
rate laws, some second-order
integrated rate laws.
Here is second-order.
We have a little equation,
2A going to B.
And the rate expression,
disappearance of A over time.
And the rate law would be equal
to k, the rate constant,
times the concentration of A.
And the order of the reaction
is second.
It is second-order,
so you know that that is a two
there.
And, again, as we talked about
last time, what you see up
there, you have A to the M.
This indicates the order of the
reaction with respect to A.
This is second order.
Now, as we did last time,
we are going to separate the
terms.
We are going to take the terms
that have to do with
concentration and put them on
one side and put everything else
on the other side,
including the time terms.
And so here we have rearranged
things.
We have brought A squared over
to one side.
We have dA over here.
We have taken the negative sign
and dt and put it on the other
side with k.
And so we have these separated.
And now we can integrate.
Again, as we did last time,
we are going to integrate from
some initial concentration of A,
the original concentration of
A, to the concentration of A at
time t.
And, on the other side,
we are going to go from zero
time to time t.
And so here is our expression.
And now we can take this and
solve this expression.
There is just the expression
again copied to the top of the
page.
We can solve this.
And we get, in brackets,
one over the concentration of A
at time t minus one over the
initial concentration of A,
the original concentration of
A, all in brackets,
with a minus.
And, on the other side,
we have minus kt,
the rate constant and the time.
Now we can rearrange
this expression.
Now we want to arrange it such
that the concentration of the
material at time t is on one
side, we have kt over here,
and one over the original
concentration of A on the other
side.
And you will see that this can
be written in a format for a
straight line.
If we plot information about
how A changes with time and,
again, with chemical kinetics,
it is all about how
concentration of things change
with time versus time,
we can get out information that
we want for a second-order
equation.
Here is what a plot would look
like.
You are plotting.
You're collecting your data.
You are collecting changes of
concentration of A,
so you are measuring the
concentration of A at given time
points.
And so you plot that versus
time.
And you should get a straight
line.
If you don't,
something is seriously wrong
with something that you are
doing.
So, you should get a straight
line.
And so the intercept of the
line would be one over the
initial concentration,
the original concentration of
A.
And then the slope of the line
is going to give you your rate
constant, which is what you
usually want to know.
You want to be measuring rate
constants for particular
reactions.
Now, let's talk about
second-order half-life.
We will start with this second
order integrated rate law.
And now half-life,
you are going to consider the
time it takes for half of your
original material to go away.
At this point,
when you are talking about
second-order,
your A(t), your concentration
of A at time t,
is half the concentration of
what you had originally here.
We can plug that in.
The concentration at the time t
that you are interested in is
now half of what you had to
start with by definition of
half-life.
Your time now has sort of a new
symbol by it.
It is t to the half
down here.
And now we can rearrange this
and solve for this.
As we rearrange it,
we can move the two up there.
And we can bring these
concentration terms to the same
side of the equation.
We can subtract now,
which gives us one over the
initial concentration of A.
And then, if we rearrange so
that we solve for the half-life,
we move the rate constant down
over here, and we can get our
expression.
What is the biggest difference
between this expression and the
one for first-order half-life?
Dependence on concentration,
right.
The concentration term is in
there.
With a first-order process,
the term for concentration is
no longer in the expression.
The half-life does not depend
on the concentration of the
original material,
but here the concentration term
is in the expression.
Second-order half-life depends
on the starting concentration of
the material.
If you were really in a lab
doing experiments,
you often need to figure out if
something is first- or
second-order.
And in the problem set you will
have some different things where
you are trying to figure out,
where I will show you how the
rate changes with different
concentrations.
And often what you do in a
laboratory is you plot data and
see whether it does fit.
I said, if you didn't get a
straight line when you are
plotting, something is wrong.
In real life,
sometimes you would be plotting
data.
You can plot data as a first
order plot.
Our first order expression was
here.
The natural log of the
concentration of A at a given
time is equal to minus kt plus
the natural log of the initial
concentration.
Here would be a plot of that.
And then for second order we
would use the equation that we
just derived.
Instead of natural log,
you are plotting one over the
concentration versus time.
And if the data really was a
second order process,
you should get something that
looks good over here.
Whereas, over here you should
get something that doesn't
really look good.
In real life,
often what you are doing is
seeing how well data fits to
some assumption that you have.
And you are deciding the orders
of reaction, you find that out
experimentally.
It is usually not given to you.
That is something that you
would be doing.
And you would be looking at how
rates change with time,
and you would be plotting out
data and seeing how well it fits
your assumptions.
Okay.
Now, we get to go back and
think about, what do rates have
to do with chemical equilibrium?
What is the connection between
rates and chemical equilibrium?
At equilibrium,
one way we can define
equilibrium is that the rates of
the forward and the reverse
reactions are equal.
Now we are thinking about
equilibrium in terms of rates.
I will leave that up,
I guess.
Let's write out our standard
reaction.
This chalk is really good.
No.
Here is a good piece of chalk.
In our standard reaction,
we have A plus B going to C
plus D.
And that is how we have been
expressing it.
Now we are going to think about
rates, so we are going to give
the forward reaction a little k
one and the backward
reaction, oh,
I am going to do k minus one.
Over the reverse and the
backward direction.
Now we can express the rate for
the forward reaction.
And we can assume,
here, that this is an
elementary reaction.
We can write our rate law
exactly the way the equation
looks.
If we do that,
the rate is going to have a
rate constant,
k one.
And it will depend on the
concentrations of our two
reacting materials,
so the concentration of A and
the concentration of B.
We can write this rate law
without doing any of the
experimental stuff,
if we are told that it is an
elementary reaction,
a simple reaction.
We can also write the rate for
the reverse reaction,
so the reaction going in the
other direction.
And so that rate law will be
equal to the rate constant for
the reverse direction,
which is k minus one,
times the concentrations of C
and D.
That is the rate in the reverse
direction.
What do we know about k?
What is big K?
Products over reactants.
C times D over A B.
That is our equilibrium
constant.
At equilibrium,
then, according to this new
definition, the rates of the
forward reaction will be equal
to the rates of the reverse
reaction.
At equilibrium,
k one,
the rate of the forward
reaction, k one times A times B
is going to be equal to k minus
one times concentration of C
times the concentration of D.
That is what happens at
equilibrium.
Rates of the forward reaction
equal rates of the reverse
reaction.
Then, if we rearrange that
expression, we will see that
that means that K is going to be
equal to k one over k minus one.
Because,
if we rearrange this,
C D divided by A B is going to
be equal to k one divided by k
minus one.
hese are equal.
You can express K in terms of
the concentrations.
And it is also going to be
equal to those two rate
constants.
What does this mean in terms of
our big equilibrium constants
and small equilibrium constants
that we have been talking about?
In kinetic terms,
when we talk about K being
greater than one --
Before, when we were talking
about the equilibrium being
greater than one,
we were talking about more
products than reactants at
equilibrium.
And we were not really talking
anything about the rates of the
reaction.
What is going to be true in
terms of these small k's,
k one and k minus one,
if big K,
if the equilibrium constant,
is greater than one,
what is true about those two?
Here, k one,
then, has to be greater than k
minus one,
or the rate constant for the
forward reaction has to be
bigger.
Rate constant for forward
reaction is bigger.
And big K, equilibrium constant
K less than one means
that the rate of the reverse
reaction, reverse rate constant
is bigger.
Now you can think about
equilibrium constants in a new
way.
You can think about them in
kinetic terms.
All right.
Now we are going to go in and
start talking about mechanisms
of reactions.
And the mechanism is one of the
important things in terms of
what affects the overall rate.
How many steps does the
reaction go in?
Are there fast steps?
Are there slow steps?
How many slow steps?
How many fast steps?
How long does it really take
for the reaction as written to
occur?
And so it is unlikely that
reactions take place in one
step.
That is not too common.
Usually, they proceed through a
series of steps.
And each step is called an
elementary reaction.
I have been mentioning
elementary reactions,
saying that for an elementary
reaction you can write a rate
law without any data.
You can just write it as is.
That is what you are doing in
terms of mechanisms.
You will see an overall
reaction and then you will try
to break it down into steps.
And each step is an elementary
reaction.
You can write a rate law for
each step and then think about
whether that reaction mechanism
makes sense in terms of the data
that is available for the
overall reaction.
Again, an overall reaction,
the order and the rate law
cannot be derived from the
stoichiometry.
You wouldn't necessarily know
if it is first-order with
respect to one thing,
second-order with respect to
something else,
you cannot do that,
but for the elementary
reaction, it occurs exactly as
written.
You have broken it down.
It is an elementary reaction or
a step.
You have broken it down so that
it is occurring exactly as
written, and then you can
predict the rate law.
You are sort of breaking down
the mechanism into the simplest
steps.
Let's look at an example for
this.
Here is the decomposition of
ozone.
You have two molecules over
here reacting to give you three
molecules of oxygen.
A proposed mechanism then has
two elementary reactions or two
steps.
And here, in the first step,
we have one molecule of ozone.
Are there questions?
It seems kind of noisy.
One molecule of ozone going to
O, oxygen by itself there,
plus O two.
This intermediate oxygen
species then comes back and
reacts with ozone again to give
two molecules of O two.
The first reaction is called
unimolecular because there is
only one thing reacting.
What do you think the next one
is called?
Right.
It is going to be called
bimolecular.
Let's put that up there.
Oh, I guess I should go back to
that.
All right.
Molecularity is the number of
reactant molecules that come
together to form product.
That is molecularity.
And the second one would be
bimolecular.
This is another one of those
questions that can turn up on
the final.
It is supposed to be the easy
points.
I ask what the molecularity is,
and you look,
there is one thing,
it's uni., there are two
things, it is bimolecular,
but people forget what that
term means.
That is a good one to kind of
keep in the back of your head.
That is just a really simple
extra few points that you can
get on a final to recognize
those terms.
All right.
We are not going to get to four
things reacting.
We will go only as much as
three things reacting.
Unimolecular,
one reactant.
An example of that would be
some kind of decomposition or
radioactive decay.
Bimolecular,
two things reacting.
Here you would have two things
coming together,
colliding to form a product.
And we will talk in the next
few lectures about the energies
associated with that reaction
occurring.
And then termolecular.
I give you that that is a
little bit of a harder one to
remember than the uni.
and bimolecular,
but the termolecular are three
things coming together to form
products.
As one might imagine,
three things all coming
together at the exact same time
to form a product sort of in one
step would be unlikely to
happen.
These are fairly rare.
Something that is written this
way, if you see something that
is written as a termolecular
reaction, you may predict right
away that that is sort of
unlikely to happen in one step.
Any of you just trying to get a
group of friends together to do
something at the same time,
knowing that getting three
people together at the exact
same time to something that you
are planning to do,
it is rare that everyone is
actually there at the same time
to start.
You can remember that that is
sort of a rare thing to happen.
But if three things did come to
react, that would be
termolecular.
All right.
Now we can consider the rate
laws for each step.
And because these are
elementary reactions or steps to
the reactions,
you can write the rate law
exactly from the reaction that
is happening exactly as written.
You can use the stoichiometry
to consider the rate law.
Let's look at the first one
then.
The rate is going to be equal
to this k one term,
the rate constant for step one,
or k one times the
reactant, which is O three,
the concentration of O
three.
That is the rate law for the
forward direction.
In this case,
there is no reverse direction
to consider.
We only have this rate law for
the first step.
In the second step,
then, we have the rate equals k
two, so that is the rate
constant for the second step.
And, in some of your problems,
you might not have these in the
book.
You should use k one for
the first step.
If there is a reverse reaction,
that should be k minus one,
k two for the
second step, if there was a
reverse reaction it would be k
minus two,
etc.
Again, these do not have
reverse steps,
so we don't have to worry about
this yet.
You will see more of these on
Wednesday on the problem set.
Here, the rate is k two times
the concentration of O times the
concentration of O three.
We can write those exactly as
written, because those are
elementary steps in an overall
reaction mechanism.
We could not write the rate law
for this, if it has multiple
steps, without experimental data
to help us do that.
Then, the individual steps
should be able to be added
together to get the reaction in
question.
And so here,
if we add this together,
we have two O threes
and we have three O twos.
And the O has canceled out.
That is an intermediate in the
reaction.
O here is a reaction
intermediate.
And the big trick in writing
reaction mechanisms and figuring
out rate laws for overall
reactions up here is to cancel
out intermediates.
You are going to spend the next
few days getting ready for the
problem set on Friday,
getting rid of intermediates in
reactions.
It doesn't appear in the
overall reaction equation and it
cannot appear in any of your
rate laws that define the
particular reaction.
Just, finally,
this is the last slide,
that reaction mechanisms are a
series of steps.
Reaction mechanisms can never
be proven to be correct.
They just can be consistent
with data.
You are going to be predicting
reactions that are consistent
with the data on this next
problem set.
Okay.
Thanks.